على وقع الحرب والمعارك تتواصل المحاولات
الدوليه للضغط على روسيا حيث اثرت المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي توقيف في حق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ومفوضه حقوق
الطفل في الرئاسه ماريا بلوفا وقال رئيس
المحكمه بيوتر
ان المذكرتين اسطرت لمسؤوليتهما في
الترحيل غير القانوني للاطفال في اوكرانيا
اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي
اعتقال مرتبطتين بالاوضاع في اوكرانيا بحق
السيد فلاديمير بوتين رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
وماريا بلوفا مفوضه الرئيس الروسي لحقوق
الاطفال بتهم ارتكاب الجرائم حرب مزعومه
تتمثل في ترحيل الاطفال من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله الى الاتحاد الروسي
يحضر القانون الدولي على القوه المحتله
نقل المدنيين من الاراضي التي يعيشون فيها
الى مناطق اخرى يتمتع الاطفال بحمايه خاصه
بموجب اتفاقيه جنيف محتويات المذكرتين
السريه من اجل حمايه الضحايا وتولي
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اهميه كبيره
لحمايه الضحايا وخاصه الاطفال ومع ذلك قرر
القضاه الذين يتعاملون مع هذه القضيه
اعلان وجود المذكرتين لصالح العداله ولمنع
ارتكاب جرائم في المستقبل